[Music]
nba legend bill russell is getting ready
to auction off some of basketball's most
valuable pieces of memorabilia later
this month they're all part of the 87
year old's personal collection including
championship rings most valuable player
trophies and game worn jerseys is being
put together by hunt auctions which much
of much of the proceeds going to his
charity mentor in a rare television
interview with the 11 time nba champion
we met on court in boston he reflects on
his life
his career and the obstacles he was
forced to overcome not just as a player
but as a black man in america
[Music]
basketball hadn't seen anything like
bill russell before
built like a skyscraper at six foot ten
when russell jumped russell soared
the kid from monroe louisiana who nobody
wanted on their team because of the
color of his skin he redefined what the
sport could be and eventually ended up
being the teammate no one could play
without bill this must been a great win
for you exactly
russell catapulted the celtics in the
city of boston skyward in the 1950s and
60s winning titles and breaking barriers
at a time when keeping your dignity as a
black man in america was easier said
than done so we're sitting here in
boston
at the garden
you helped bring glory here
11 championships here what does it feel
like to be here
on this court
i never was
comfortable plan for the celtics because
the number one paper was the boston
herald and they didn't like the idea
of the nba team having black players you
brought championships here in the time
when it was hard to be a black man was
it difficult
to be celebrated on the court
but then off of it not treated equal
first of all
was never separated on the court when i
got there was
the star was bob cousy
watch boston's bob cruisey no matter
what i did cause it was a star bill
russell another celtic taps it in i
remember i had a game where i had 25
points 25 rebounds 10 blocks and
boston harold said i was lucky i got to
play with cozy was it tough to play
in this city was it was it easy to win
over the fans i never bothered with them
fans because when i was a star the fans
called him the boston globies
like the boston globetrotters yeah
because you guys had black players yeah
i'm not a basketball player i am a man
who plays basketball bill russell the
man is someone who stood up for the
rights and dignity of all men
bill russell wasn't just an icon for
basketball fans to rally behind on the
floor of the boston garden on any given
night nine top negro athletes meet with
cassius clay he was an icon for black
america using his profile to highlight
racism and inequality
here with muhammad ali and other top
black athletes in 1967 backing ali's
decision refusing the vietnam war draft
at the march alongside dr king in
washington all while resetting the
standard of what was possible the boston
celtics were the first team to start
five black players and i believe they
got some backlash for that and our back
said
we just put the guys on the court that
were going to help us win and that's how
he looked at basketball well he got back
had a problem in boston that was
overwhelmingly
anti-black
they considered our back a traitor
because he coached black players yeah
see we were the first team to start five
black players do you remember in
kentucky where you and your teammates
set out because they refused
service at a restaurant
yeah
at that time why did you feel like it
was important to do that well things are
part of our
preparations for the game the team would
have
dinner together
and i had a couple of teammates from
kentucky
and they were going to have a separate
pregame meal
so i told the coach i'm not going to
play tonight he said why not
i said cause of that
later that month this letter found its
way to russell's mailbox it was from
jackie robinson who broke major league
baseball's color barrier more than a
decade earlier thanking russell for
boycotting the game in kentucky jackie
was of much more to him than most people
knew
they just knew he was the first black
player in the major leagues
jackie would not take anything off
anybody that's right
and so we're gonna play uh
the knicks
and he says uh
i'm to tell you guys i probably am of
you
jackie was uh not only tough
but he's probably the smartest guy to
ever play baseball i tried to get as
many as him i couldn't get there
which championship was the most special
to you was it the first one
or was it the last one the first year i
was player coach and we won a
championship first black coach in the
nba
is that right yeah
and you won as a player and a coach yeah
well you gotta understand something my
motivation was to make myself acceptable
to my folks i never felt like i was
making the contribution
i was just doing the best i could
the best he could wow one of the
greatest you know i wanted to talk about
what he did on the court and he kept
going back to what he accomplished off
of the court we love bill russell
because of his talent but i think we
need to admire him because of how he
handled
being a player
but being a black man at that time just
think about that dynamic
he was looked at as superhuman off the
court and less than human off of it
it's what you highlighted in this piece
nate and that it sort of dovetails with
what bill russell told you which is that
the game of basketball is a great game
but what you do with that platform for
your people and how you want to be seen
by the people is just as important if
not more and he and jackie robinson did
it well yeah so many others that came
after them all these young players yeah
guys like bill russell how do you want
to be remembered that's right when
you're done playing that's right
excellent what a wonderful piece we'll
be right back